[ __ ] ladies and gentlemen we got we
got the timbre the timbre the baritone
of Adam right in the house the sexiest
voice we've ever had on the phone boil
take it well I want you to I want you to
do it fair before we do anything I want
you ask in your in your sexiest voice Oh
what do you say once you lose that shirt
and get you moving around the corner
over there hey Brian yeah got a couple
ideas for you real quick yeah I know
it's Wednesday I know it's midweek yeah
we're at basement what's going on yeah
great basement yeah I know you're like
you like these fancy basement side B's
basements with just a couple mics and a
couple chairs never said that I here's
the idea I wanted to get to okay yeah
once you lose that shirt fine go play
with yourself in the corner what was the
second part of it around move around
around a little rattled around the
corner I like play with a jump like
waterbed that's so good take a look I
just go ahead and move around the corner
I mean also is ridiculous as me same
play with yourself look like just move
around dig around then you can add
something more outside creepy though you
know hear me move around and then you
can say some but I guess it's like
dealer's choice like whatever move
around means not your friend will dude
and then when I'm listening when I move
around I want you to go I want you to
really quietly say that I'll make a
noise with your money okay I'll do it
[Laughter]
hey Brian yeah happy Wednesday first of
all oh happy one yeah people don't say
that midweek and a fun day terrific
Tuesday
Freaky Friday okay I'm about to mid week
compliments okay after Wednesday kappa
yeah i know you love shirts I don't know
but I'm looking to get rid of that shirt
why don't you take that shirt off bright
but go to that corner huh move around
for a little bit move around yeah you
know how to move around yeah I guess
I've been doing it for years now it's
staging off like this slower now faster
come I do a slow fast combo keep your
torso type move your head like a peacock
notice a applying the peacock Allen it's
a nickname
what's so comfortable no you're very
cold you look comfortable okay I'm
making noise with your mouth what you
heard me it safe with the same concern
that you said what oh there it is
quickly it
oh yeah it is how about your toes will
your socks up [ __ ] so [ __ ]
delicious
that's Adam ray is a porn director in
the heat game dude when we were in
masters at the moon territory festival
you did was a Comedy Jam
yeah yeah I'm chill right and I posted
Brian singing who sings mother by
dancing like a hood you pry it open
there dude I mean that was like a tough
like it was hilarious you followed it
dude and then you went up I we were
laughing so hard about you already man
cuz you're tight and I don't know that
you're better with it I don't give it
away but you talked about how you used
to work at an Albertan yeah for those
better listen and you're on the west
coast Albertson is like our ralph don't
know where you're out it's like grouse
or you know pretty big like grocery
store chain right a lot of people know
they don't know what it is like yeah
with the Albertsons that guy what is
that like Albertsons or King Soopers is
there King Soopers in Seattle no no with
like Safeway hell yeah the Safeway yeah
top I thought what was awesome right
your let goes on before we go move on B
the thing is is what I related to is you
talk about how you worked at Albertsons
and there's a kid who also worked with
you yeah down syndrome yeah I feel like
every Albertsons has the token Down
syndrome worker sure because I work that
was my first gig I was a janitor at
Albertsons and there's a kid with Down
syndrome where a janitor I was janitor
terrible flu they didn't put you leg
sweeper I would have put you with the
customer service booth because it's like
yo I mean I'm sure you know or heard of
like the insane complaints like people
would probably feel like maybe I
shouldn't
I wasn't that big then I was like 7 is
16 so I was in big house early in it I
was skinny I was
you know and hashtag late-bloomer hash
that hashtag terrible employee hashtag
you know 25 cents we're supposed to put
in 25 cents to take candy yeah I would
just pretend I put centum and steal
shitload of candy could free 10 I was a
little saline in the bathroom and just
read magazines eat candy forever till
they fired me dude they cast the
characters of grocery stores I mean like
that's one of a thousand stories that I
have and I should probably I mean comply
to a one-man show on it and it's like I
mean that customer service with I did
that for two years and the complaints I
got from people that were so I mean
that's really I think when I started to
like form a comedic brain because I was
like seeing the stupidity where I was
like you
have to be [ __ ] with me like this
woman came in one time we had a 25-cent
a plus cold machine outside and she
comes in she goes excuse me I just
clicked nine dollars worth of quarters
in that a place soda machine trying to
get a lemon-lime soda and it kept giving
me boot beer and she has a whole [ __ ]
like 19 sodas and she drops from the
counter and she's like I would like my
money back and I go oh that is that
sucks were small let me just address
agree with you that 19 lemon limes when
all you wanted was a root beer is
[ __ ] yeah
that being said didn't it like four
dollars you stop and go maybe I'm not
getting living live today maybe she goes
are you calling me stupid
I go you said I didn't your oldest they
just couldn't keep my mouth shut
she calls over the manager he comes over
obviously customer's always right so
he's like I know it so good
here's your money back and keep the
sodas Adam II can't do that much she's
[ __ ] that's crazy doors like we can't
just let me get away that Merrick yeah
we can cuz that's what we do where she
trying to basically steal no I just
think really just what it was like yes I
was like so adamant about I put in like
but I was like yo like 12 quarters deep
you weren't like ya did alright there's
no show you when you work more quarters
and then maybe you work in a place like
that and like I worked at McDonald's you
can't believe that our democracy works
it's like you can't believe it and
everybody's allowed to have them vote I
know I have [ __ ] regular but also you
like I can't believe how bad people
treat those employees like people
treated me like you have 16 relax man I
was a Janet they treated me like janitor
like a janitor but like the item Edward
who was 8 to worse the kid who was 18
that they just put a Starbucks in he
thought he was [ __ ] mister steal yo
girl like he would literally like bosses
around I'm like if you uh you do a good
work I might I might whip up a
Frappuccino fo really is I'd like to do
it whip up well I tried like chin on
girls cuz yep
I worked out one it was uh the influence
one across street from Cherry Creek High
School where all the hot girls were they
literally it's like where you want to be
and do they I would see them like oh
hell yeah I'll act like a mop and like
what's up you're like oh my god what
what the [ __ ] going on like you're
generally yeah
that makes sense all this how you teach
an attorney it is how it goes I was
horrible me yeah III yesterday I never
got any tail by never really and then it
was so depressing in the in the in the
worst part that they should make a
reality show on is in the break room so
just the people dollar for share it's
like the size your life I watch what's
your horrible day what's your like just
people with scream yeah yes ranting
story yesterday I came I had a checkup
at the doctor's another one no I had
that was my call Oscar I mean I had to
get a Franco I hadn't had a physical
hash tag in perfect health
I think hash tag quick doing the doctors
for everything the doctor that I went to
is a Sikh he is a white guy but inside
you see don't go to that guy he's kind
of long beer give me don't go there I
know and I said like how many
colonoscopies have you had this is just
that one just one and I came back clean
bill of health now a hunch of God taken
and they took 10 11 vials of blood he's
like a lot it does it does I don't know
this is a very thorough time players
give that much blood I don't know I'm
glad to drink orange juice nope I didn't
drink anything I just took a shitload of
blood and I don't feel light-headed no
no I'm very strong but the guy I came
back down after he he he looked at me
and poked me and prodded me and put his
fingers in my ass yeah I have an 18 year
olds prostate I got a flat beautiful
prostate for you yeah no I don't know
about are legit sanitizes but flattened
beautiful like nothing even a fat like a
peach in trouble you're a trouble and if
you have nodes he looks I mean he said
you're 50 and I said yes and he said but
I feel like Jon Lovitz that talks
because you look much younger I was
trying to [ __ ] oh there we go
no no sound of flow he'd nope he's
really done but it may be spiritually
and so I found out that he is actually
among doctors because my my sister had a
health scare for a while if that found
out that he is renowned he's a renowned
western doctor but right integrative
medicine medicine as well yeah but when
they have a question of the doctors go
to that guy and ask him question he just
- no he's just that you need just know
it's crazy long story short I leave him
and I go down to the valet in Beverly
Hills where some of the worst people in
the world live
yep stuffed
okay and the guy goes I give my credit
card because we don't take cash
sorry and I go ah all right
Miz there he goes there's one right
across the street sir and I go okay told
you enough that we could good yeah
because it was dat it was down below the
building though right and it's 20 bucks
so I have to go all that and get cash
and then I give him cash and I give him
a $5 tip and he goes to me I just want
to thank you I said why is it because
you know everybody when they found
there's no money here you know no cash
no idea they yell at me they yell all
day they yell at me and the other guy
was going yeah it's true man thank you
thank you for know me for not yelling at
us I go what do you mean what do you use
everybody and as he's saying that I
swear to god a woman and man come out
and they go you don't take you don't
take credit cards that's ridiculous
how then what am I supposed to do and my
bull you know I tell my both ladies
night what do you want me to do he's got
to just work in their ass off in your
and your and I felt so bad for those who
that they deal with that [ __ ] they're
underground they're underground
who gets getting cars and they deal with
that from rich people all a lot of fun
but they're like NBA referees just no
thanks and car line you know and he was
a lot of wrong again and I said it's
okay and then I ran its foot over
because he she needs to me off the
labrum because he needs it America take
ass slap this [ __ ] try us that's
right it is Everly Hills Helen yes it
does good of course I'm moving around a
little bit what did you stay at where
Hollywood yeah I live a block in the
Laugh Factory
okay I'm so close yeah and your best
friends Brad Williams probably not fair
to say I gotta have a [ __ ] yeah for
sure gotta have a major that I have
joking [ __ ] yeah we don't have a token
[ __ ] no we should have like a bidding
word for Brad but don't say token [ __ ]
because well know he has one in this
crew yeah once I think once you know I
was never I manually know the protocol
with the M word I'm like but dwarfism is
what he has and so that's usually what I
say like when my niece's who've met Brad
and figures hilarious and you know they
they asked who they go is he going to be
small forever asked adorable questions
like that you know and and I go I don't
know like modern medicine were ball
thanks a lot of milk yeah
yeah turn into away I don't think of
Brad it's so funny when you're around
them yeah I mean oh you it goes away so
good it goes away unless you go but when
I started traveling with him is when we
started becoming friends you know when
you have somewhere in the road and like
that's when you just you guys you get
away he has real bits together oh yeah I
do the podcast about were like four
years ago and at the gentle Evans comedy
club and I never wanted to do a podcast
cuz I guess at that time I just thought
you had to do it by yourself so I was
like god that's market so saturated and
I just didn't think I you don't want to
listen to myself talk by myself and and
doing it with somebody seemed really
appealing I can't imagine doing one by
yourself right like can you guys have to
doing this I don't think so I wouldn't
want to do one by Matt kind I mean I'm
sure we can all fill the space in the
time but it's like but don't use cash
too though right it depends
yeah but the first town house usually
you're breaking off for real lights and
that's something specific to talk about
yeah what different yeah just a general
bill burr doesn't delete them yes
they're brilliant at it yeah I guess
that's probably so you started a podcast
with Brad but where did the
relationships start with Brad I mean
what's up York I was you know I was in a
park and and I heard some chirping from
a tree and I woke up and he was up in
this killing the eggs used to be an
anaconda or appendix from a conduit and
they did the small smaller people like
they live on eggs wild on game eggs
I'm very impressive yeah I didn't a lot
of people to know that I'm I really like
skittles and cookies
okay well that's you know that's what
they want you to think very it all the
eggs very effective climbers they have
retractable claws I'm just saying what
the Discovery Channel says but maybe and
they raid they raid raid nests that
wouldn't admit it but he wouldn't admit
it he no we met at USC actually I went
there for acting school and he was a
judge at a comedy contest that they did
a year after I graduated that like Brad
hosts it was for alumni and people that
were attending USC and was at the big
auditorium and Jeff Ross and Russell
Peters like Judge Dredd hosted it so
that's first time I met him and then he
started coming on the comedy store and
and we just you know for dudes it's like
you know sports comedy like don't be an
[ __ ] and like you can bond pretty
quickly
you know girls need like excursions you
know like he can dance by the way
he can [ __ ] tackle I'm gonna send you
a link that April's he was time adapting
a courtside he went courtside or
somebody like you should you were in a
[ __ ] SuperSonics Jersey yeah analyst
really frowned upon know well here's why
though so I lost my basketball team
right the see also troops
yes drafted Kevin Durant like thank you
we're all set yeah it was the worst man
it's like you know drafting him and then
Westbrook and then they leave and
they're so good right away it was like
and then you're having to watch that
like ninety nine out it was like you
chick leaves you she goes and [ __ ] a
bunch of dudes on TV and you have to
watch yeah sort of yeah [ __ ] if you're
that much more fan that is yeah so I
guess you know and I didn't do it all
the time but like it was anytime I'll go
to a game I was just so I think was
still very fresh to where I was like I'm
just gonna be so Pro Seattle and I know
like look I also it's like yet when
people were the another Jersey at the
game Thursday share the same same
overwhelming [ __ ] doing man those two
teams that team is not being represented
right now but uh but I was just so hard
Seattle everything trying to make a
statement - like courtside I get you're
showing your loyalty yeah and people tag
me on Instagram Twitter someone just
tagged me this morning they're like look
at this [ __ ] get Oklahoma Houston game
and he's in the Lakers Jersey yeah
they're just like what are you doing man
you know it's just this what people do
at those games yeah also too I mean I
think the better question too is like at
what age do you stop wearing jerseys you
know yeah I fell out whatever one one
cuz you're not a hoops guy right but do
you guys for sport and all-around
athlete I'm a sportsman right so you
know anymore like the universal jersey
like a tight team and all he was like a
FUBU jersey I wear would you wear I
would wear a salsa jersey I'm old I was
enthusiast you know what D'Elia says
about when New Jersey right you know
Julia's bitters yeah well if you run
into that grandbaby yeah he deserves the
butter [ __ ] you for the name yes [ __ ]
it's to blow these guys you got his name
on your back Cajun [ __ ] it make sense
it's so you're making skate up to you
okay
[ __ ] you and then skate away you're my
robbery dude in Seattle because the
reason why the Sonics are so big there's
yeah the Shawn Kemp and Gary Payton's
exactly Detlef Schrempf yeah really
running to you hahahaha I know because
Shawn came had
99 a legitimate case all you know about
a man you don't know about his
high-flying dog Shawn Kemp could [ __ ]
and yeah donk
all right well - any other guys Gary
Payton and then Terry pay that guy has a
big hand Detlef Schrempf deadly shrimp
now that deadly has a name yeah catalyst
shrimp you open like a you open like
some sort of like Burlington Coat
Factory knockoff or sandwich shop if
that's your name because like got the
shrimp you the [ __ ] Jersey Mike's
dead let's race ramps I don't know him
you you know like the major like LeBron
jealous guys Steffi Graf you're probably
big Steffi Graf fans like you know kind
of like I gotta follow 2 nephi around
the world I made heard I was a glam
Panna impacting yeah well you were big
Andre Agassi pain but you I'd rather I
go to Steffi Dondre well I'm a tennis
player my forehand are you Rick
yeah do you watch it Dobby I don't watch
enough of it I love Watson you didn't
Agassi win Wimbledon on meth no lots of
you uh whatever room of it when he was
younger his dad would give him room he's
a he's not given up it would give man
feta means to keep him kicked it like so
what he says enough if he was losing his
energy and it was a big tournament his
dad would give he and his brother a
little some some yeah messed up hey Dad
for sure if I can relay that we do that
is nothing I'm gonna do oh yeah it
worked
dad says his dad so in his book his dad
was an Iranian guy he was on the big
boxer and he trained his son and his son
from like probably what three was out
with that ball machine and I think they
call I think Android called the ball
machine the dragon the point is when he
won level 10 to 21 years old and that's
great on YouTube just bring out when
Andre Agassi wins Wimbledon final points
also I love coach time I mean else I
love that you know less about Shawn Kemp
and more about Papa Agassi's
like that that's right that says what
about you but that's what I love about
my town my County well also Braun who
talked about steady grass nice London
she's bucket or terrible obvious east
wind rose won Wimbledon when he won
Wimbledon he had estimated that he had
hit I believe it was 2.2 million balls
off that on that fat dragon you know
that bad drag yet just consoled one of
the others -
call them his Eva's crying the other on
to check out his dad right so he wins
home with him the greatest the most
spectacular thing to win and his dad is
crying and his father says his father as
he gets through the tears because but
you missed that one shot real real
that's what that guru the didn't bring
it over and you didn't shoot why don't
you big dad like that I still had a
critique and that's how he grew up and
so he he in his eyes like good baby huh
he says I hated tennis I hated it
no no you didn't like no no I hated
tennis I think I think people are
surprised to find out about that liked a
lot of professors out these big hurt
just because they're good at it that
people think it's like their love do you
think he feels like he wasted a chunk of
his life hundred percent well they let
him to wear his epaulet what is he
hiding he's actually amazing because he
instead of grass started a school in in
Las Vegas probably okay that's amazing
and and they have been a lot of our life
now it is now it is now that's what he's
doing his gotta do that's part of his
life so you think all the moments like
that they cut to him where he was need
some right oxygen but he if he even
notice actually none I'm thinking about
it like even when he smiled it never
really seemed like a full genuine smile
it was almost like this is how you smile
as a person right and I also didn't have
the guitar did it help any had to wear a
wig he was wearing a wig did he went
away stole done yeah because he was
losing his hair and a huge part of his
marketability don't worry about really
the fact that he had was in the fact
that he had long sexy hair started
losing it and had to [ __ ] always walk
around with a hat and a wig on that a
lot of times that would you see is a wig
and it was that's enough that's a hand
never came off right mid-game cuz that
would have been just the greatest piece
of footage I agree I've been awesome I
remember he really he was also fairly
under sized for a lot of the players you
know and he when he started winning that
look at that was kidding come on in that
goatee
yeah and he was yeah did he go on
upwards that Oprah was a dr. Phil we
just started crying about everything
probably Oprah Oprah Gary I feel like
people don't want to cry in front of so
they until he makes you cry sorry you
know go on over to cry doctor feels like
I noticed you're not crying you well why
is there some I'm also wrong with you
well when I had done I feel sigh huge I
didn't know
you know that yes nine calls football
now Alex nine okay dude do you Google
dr. sleep at night maybe I'll talk about
the height requirements don't never talk
so much okay
hey anything to eat salad off Agassi and
nuts I want to talk about yes no thing
about him though she's usually three
eggs every morning no no that what I was
going to say is this I did a suddenly
Susan issues with vigilant yeah and
brushing away this at the time she's a
doll but at a time she was she was
talking about how yeah it was a guy who
was calling her house her and Andre
Agassi and giving them the date and the
time of when he was going to come kill
them and chop them in little pieces well
in Pete's a by his defense he was just
trying to [ __ ] and get understand
hahahaha but he's a little hard he was
his credit horrible impersonator so he'd
be like hey he called by going hey this
isn't Pete Sampras and they're like what
definitely here and then he still just
had his voice was like anyway I'm gonna
kill you ever acted P we talked to me
earlier today man we know he really just
doing like a [ __ ] villain version of
your voice in your voice so did you
sound like a villain the villain point
phrase but I get not P campus before he
hangs out so anyway they called into
that you're gonna die caps Anna and so
they found out who the guy was and Andre
Agassi had a strength coach named kill
who is this giant man yeah baby and he
what he would do with these situations
and they got a lot of them he would get
on plane and fly to their house [ __ ] and
knock on the door and this giant man
would go hey take a fish away get here
let yourself move around a little round
a little bit there you go that's what he
would say how would they get their asses
install lucky he had a lot of money so
there's ways right private but also how
is there now did they get the house
number as well they would just heck hire
a private detective it you can trace a
call how did they get Andre Agassi's
house number
oh I don't know I'm sure you can always
find somebody there's a way if right now
you were like yo show me the nearest
Dairy Queen in Portland Oregon
like somebody will find it for you yeah
six nine dr. Phil OH find a point what
sing or I'm not good I feel like you're
spreading rumors a with doctors and
maybe bring in a cardboard cutout from
home that's I won't
where's Agassiz from I think my Vegas
right yeah he did not a lot of people
come out of Vegas man there's a great
movie waiting to be made about his life
I feel like right that's pretty I don't
know yeah you're right you know what
it's a happy ending he's fine and he
actually killed it his whole life he was
transom struggles I'm just trying to
find a way for to get you cash to Steffi
Graf's like that I know it's a dream all
you've been talking about for a while
her dad her dad yeah was just like his
dad and they almost came to blows
Jesus what a scene dude thinking the
first time we've done it you know bad
dads yes grab me I got a dad and see
that yeah your mark graph what's this
Martin I don't know he's some German guy
probably hans and having to do the
movies like people always think I'm mark
McGrath like nobody thinks that dude all
right you're just trying to associate
well they said the first time I met they
came back out with like snacks or
something and the two of them had their
shirts off and they were circling each
other on the court like tonight like two
sides there to pray come up in a
physical fight now if tennis was smart
in a marketing homerun they would go all
right it's Agassi versus grass in a do
all fight for the marriage one set
policy Papa growth and papa graph and
pop Agassi follow up they fight on the
court after the tennis match yeah I'm
not mad that they could use a dating
come on dude like that more fights in
tennis that's white like mackerel agate
like even the amount of emotion and
maybe it was fueled by in feta means but
guess what I love it
I mean I fights in sports I think to the
best of me like I watched that Pacers
Pistons ball you hope saw that right
yeah I mean that to me when they went
into the standard 10 just I look that
was Leno when some guy like me trying to
fight Ron Artest yeah grunts in the face
yeah you try to fight run up this know
when a guy like me oh yeah say like
average Joe like come on a lot of karate
I take her out haven't done some boxing
then you get a super athlete in running
yet and you go oh because you can see
him go oh wait this is different I fell
through eight take a game also so many
of those Pacers which was so great were
I mean look there these athletes are so
just fired up to to go to war so it's
like the fact that they had an
opportunity now to like unleash like
during the game like I mean the 90s were
different for the NBA I was like there
was so much more
myself lingo yeah guys throwing guys the
ground now guys like you know getting
each other's face and then they wait for
their teammates to separate them and
nothing's ever going to happen because
they know they'll get slide for the 75k
fine and they're like a lot of money
like you know that job as your sponsor
hasn't come in yet that's a lot of money
you know and by the way it's not coming
in Jamba Juice's and sponsor athletes
but they might sponsor comedians this is
me right now
so actually jobless real quick real
quick no geometers I got to make a Bryan
Callen in the corner sipping on the
strawberry razzmatazz red want to can I
stop tipping here that said is that a
baby calf drinking a Capri Sun or a
grown man with a six-pack taking a
razzmatazz in the duck
I like this may give me a headache hmm
there we go
you're almost on you'd be almost done so
much put on this head cross your eyes
why I fired my stepdaughter why so weird
Jamba Juice you never know what's going
down but doing great
come on Jamba Juice hey our jumper is
real around also that'd be great like
you'd be in the dark you know like those
old frost plagues Tony the Tiger
commercials yeah we're like they'd be
interviewing him like in the dark
yeah he was like yes clearly brownie is
that frog legs are like new it's like
that we know it's you Tony
like you're the only [ __ ] guy who
sounds like you're soloing out of a hand
so old you know cool yeah dude but you
could be like that guy but we know it's
you because you got a very distinct
voice wait did you hear about this story
that you're reminding me of this of the
guy who frosted flakes guide to the
voice is steady grass dad
I did not head Wow full circle whole
circle
speaking of full circle right you hear
this [ __ ] did you hear about three
was found dead in Li who [ __ ] guy to
two days ago and we're in um you know
Mann's Chinese Theater yeah okay so on
right behind the curtain
no found dad's I had to go to a famous
man think Ross when Kim found dead in a
pool of milk
oh he's gonna start I'm waiting for it
when Anna's sliced but may cornflakes
your bacon all this [ __ ] up
I'm not making all this I'm not making
up [ __ ] and all look at us and all all
evidence suggests it was the work of a
serial killer
is this a bit all right if I D be with
that a bit are you trying to joke around
just that's one
Raiders old and terrible chakra so bad
hope you have a you know man it's all
delivery and timing for that know the
funniest dude Miami activator told I
joke and he did it in such a way where
he was doing stuff and he goes
they found a sky in a puddle milk and
bananas sliced on his body and then he
was oh my god and then he had cornflakes
olive oil what and all evidence yeah it
was very odd all evidence points to the
work of a serial killer
oh my god we always like did you guys
get it right away I was all delivery so
drive and I was like why I was I was
like wow I was laughing so [ __ ] hard
you stupid you ya know for the people
who didn't get it did he after like hit
over the head and be like yeah there's a
killer walked away you went
trickster for kids and you're like okay
now I can't alright good now he says
that when they kill somebody I don't
think I felt what Mac did say have to
change no way did they away requirement
on cereal because they can't market like
they can't put toys in cereal anymore
because they can't market the sugary I
guess cuz cereal tall is that is because
remember I've never I was very of what
like cereal just what I'd reach in there
at dude never know what you're going to
get don't was the ridge and then that
food and nutrition board was in it sort
of basically influenced by the big big
food like Mars and craft so mate okay I
want to do other products and also they
can't I'm almost positive we have to
look this up but you can't have cartoon
characters on the boxes anymore Wow
pretty sure compliment a real should I
think you're right with a real sugary
one I know they can't have like they
can't have toys in there and you also
like Happy Meals to its know the Happy
Meals they don't do toys anymore either
with the davidsburg I got kids and
trying to keep them off for sugar is a
constant it's an assault mean I don't
want to be extreme so I let them eat
some sugar but god damn it do you see a
lot of that you also can't masturbate in
Burger King bathrooms anymore and I
don't know when that is like that but
dude Wendy's you can go for any else but
Wendy's has always been so progressive
you know they're like you know we have
like the for what's the thing like the
full corner of burgers Lindy's yeah we
had a square burger yeah square burger
hello we have Lenny bit of fresh fresh
buns you know you can jerk off and the
bad
that yourself is there I've never heard
that Burger Kings like have it your way
and they were looking out of your
wedding they're like alright we didn't
mean that way Paul jr. let you [ __ ]
already price of just talking but that
was a great piece of audio by the way I
want that we might really mellow cause
do you let you [ __ ] could you do good
new junk-food add rules kill off Tony
does so you can't the new AdWords are
banning people from putting celebrities
and characters on their products to sell
the children because that's why you're
buying it obviously cuz like Froot Loops
you don't see anymore that [ __ ] okay
a play Amir that's [ __ ] just my
salmon fresh oh thanks man
I said Weston there's a charred fire my
cartoon spokesman impression teacher hey
I hear that is time looking at Kim
Kardashian's ass I don't know god damn
did she sell cereal she could sell
anything right he could literally could
sell me on Scientology she got her ass
out I would want that sign up now what's
supposed to is it getting bigger as out
there I did should I make like this
picture on the heat light everyone knew
it was fake like we've people in sale it
for how do you get many well no forever
that she's been pumping it with stuff to
make you exigent to make it was done the
same so those pictures those pictures
are not fake no her ass is fine no no no
way man I'm not mad at that
well she's gonna wear like a baby but
yeah the problem is because her legs he
helped usually the quads match the ass
yeah for her it's not there running is
great don't you look great
it's just the back ends oh he looks
ridiculous her legs a lot of work that
you think she loves it or do you think
she's like man maybe a couple too many
injections um on the phone actually I
showed her Facebook message I didn't
post she says she's cool with it oh
there it is definitely her by the way
there's no checkmark well Wow what are
people probably just slaying her right
well then there's probably I think with
the amount of uh you know I don't care
rating she gets people were probably
she's got a good amount of supporters
they're probably like oh my people alone
every night I've got to add that but
yeah her Inc like the code Astron have a
[ __ ] clan man and I try to watch one
episode of that show on a plane one so I
got about 10 minutes it'll bum you out
do it if you miss any episode here it is
so today we're going to go get some new
shoes because we have an event tonight
and then establishing shots like Beverly
Hills booked
what do you think do you think the new
ones all about Rob come on Rob could you
live together
he's 400 pounds that mansion is not have
you seen it Kim homes lost is Kate
living the new one no she's barely in it
she did she's there know the family she
comes in she goes anybody got any
frosted flakes no sheshe pieces out and
goes there spin off dude she acts like
you know like she only comes in to
promote some like a show again a mask
and she act like it's all good that
she's feed her dad that she's their
stepmom yeah and she's like get a mass
she's like so I have a new book coming
out it's like opens up in it and then
she does the pictures I'll take care
she's like next season now look I'm
working
Kayla Jake yeah oh my god what are you
getting I had this question just rock
give me a general question do you think
that do you think that the Kardashians
there what they stand for in their shows
it's a question yes you think that they
are harmful in any way 100% yeah they
all harm yep oh yeah I don't I don't see
a benefit from it I think because you
can't say like you've yeah but you have
a daughter you do have kids out of two
nieces yeah but I'm not gonna but we
also have a gasps not the same I know
that's what I was about to say because I
hate people that do that to know I've
never done that by the way I'm not that
guy okay thanks am I the greatest uncle
of all uncles ha I mean that's dudes I
mean a lot of people are saying that
okay I don't hate what has declined dr.
Phil a couple shows ago hey I ended a
show you know Baba he should be like get
your pet spayed and neutered feels like
Adam really greatest uncle ever ever
cries does not get high every time he
reads them a bedtime story he's sorted
out sits there for 20 minutes and goes
to be continued and his nieces go that
story was terrible you just sat there in
silence and said to be continued and he
says well I'm sorry I didn't know I was
going to babysit last minute I was
getting high watching SportsCenter and
then your mom said she wanted to go out
last minute because she never goes out
because that's a real method good a good
six foot nine I knew I knew dr. Phil
before a growth spurt now he's already
more Khimki that's what we told ya
do you think it's all harm it works go
off on because if like before it does
that seven cats but which so you have a
daughter yeah
what example would they set like what's
the lesson could learn from them be a
lesson it sounds like to me that they
they're trying to set is that it's it
what matters is what you look like yep
not not so much what you can accomplish
right a schedule like it there's no
skill involved I do the mom as far as
Mark and I get that but there's no
there's really no skill their skill is
they have spectacle they have you know
they have it's a good-looking family
they have a ton of plastic surgery it's
a faker I hooked up with just famous
black guys and like that's and it's all
what can I do what can I do and I branch
out from there oh we started this
clothing line this makeup company like
also when your life is that produced
there's no way you can be a normal
person and stuff not real we know shows
like when they get together and it's
like I don't even think I'm sure they're
always on the phones like when they're
talking on the show and asking them
questions about it so what's going on
whatever you think that is probably the
most they inquire about each other's
life everything's a business like that's
it around the bike you like you can tell
they don't have real conversations like
so like self stays like so Rob haven't
seen him forever what's up yes all any
cool babies he's all not much trying to
get this sock deal don't hey I'm having
a real issue with it well maybe you have
to join up yeah yeah it's not my real
almost like their God is vanity like
they did it's just about how you look
and how you can play Kylie Jenner is
literally like the Madonna to the
younger generation like she's so big
she's because she sold because she's
glamorous because she's on yeah and
she's the new Kardashian she's gonna do
clogging I like the other ones a little
they've been around for a while now he
had a plastic surgery she had plastic
surgery to look like Kim - Kim getting
older so they want this new throne
coming yeah they tailored her to look
like your sister I might be seen her
before if you can bring it up do pre
post Kylie surgery pretty like what do
you know like you had a little girl and
pose like what the [ __ ] is like they're
it's like they're writing kind of like
vem BOTS like they're kind of like or
they're it's like weird sighing I'll be
racist slur like their doctor is this
black dude like you know
Hey Dude there you go no way any other
brain-busters yeah I do that's [ __ ]
amazing uh you know what it is - how
does she know yeah
it's TV like look before reality TV what
took that here were all role models
Doogie Howser right doctor - 9 or role
model for sure and I will stand by that
guy damn it open our surgery while he's
taking a spelling tonight man that but
look at that difference
- girl no but it was like Doogie taught
you Oh show you put your mind to it you
can do anything
in Christ Prince of Bellaire conditions
like yo you put your mouth on it you can
also do anything only we can have
anything yes I think I can be right back
that's how I thought you want to sweet
sweet Jamba Juice hey man hey man look
at you am trying to get you guys you
know you can't do like women tonight
look at that though without her lips and
everything and she had her breasts not
on everything else I'm dead-ass she said
our hips filed down and then they blew
out her ass this makes me think of and
have you guys seen this all over the
internet people this face app where
people are posting a four picture thing
of themselves where it's like you
haven't seen this know his face that
that shows you Wow on the right side
meet the [ __ ] I mean that thing I
don't care it a lot well she's had done
how does he argue with that it's an
amazing plenty of surgery job I'll tell
you that much so she as a kid is getting
as a kid she she is she says she's the
message because our culture doesn't make
you feel good about yourself so as a kid
our culture tells a young girl who's
very pretty by the way there that you're
not good enough and that you need to go
under the knife and and do a whole bunch
of yes to yourself
yes yeah I got a problem of that too I
don't want my daughter
don't you walk in this and I certainly
don't the problem is that builds your
social status but hold on the ha let's
just go over that family's trucks right
now all right let's go over it the dad
who's a beast lawyer so card asking dad
passed away right Oh Jeff Simpsons -
thankfully all that dies right it's okay
he's gone in comes Bruce Jenner
who's one of the greats Olympian of all
time that's what you've been used to he
goes I've just been a fun ride
I'm gonna I'm a chick yeah I'm a chick
like what the [ __ ]
then your show starts blowing up and
then your sister makes a sex tape
Ray J yeah and that time we shoot 18 mg
streams and the moms of where baby
shoots yes they research the moms aware
of it signed off on it yeah four shots
the quote and they won't blow up on e
and then everyone's doing their own
thing I think it starts with the mom
like she just had like a game plan from
the get-go was probably like yo this is
like a unique crew and cast like we all
kind of looked the same
I'm willing to like I mean they probably
got like plastic surgery what they were
like in elementary school don't you
think twelve one third I don't know I
don't know but I do think that she
definitely did a good job you monetizing
her children and who I've never seen Tim
Tebow say no to a picture to anyone ever
my life we're at a steak house in
Hollywood and the mom was there tried to
have patrons like uh-uh
really good for Tenten cuz I always
thought it seemed like really wow not up
in here he just he just stole yeah I was
like damn that's crazy don't let me get
itself yeah
as I can't put a good word is Ty Lee
nothing looks black like it Danny
wait you can keyboards date and Kylie no
what no Tebow Chris I'm trying to get I
got on your train rumors Rob control I
know you give them on our progress make
up [ __ ] and then it's like what extra
used to do where you break up [ __ ] hold
it hit and then they go like it's
clearly they did it this for so long
where they make up stories just to have
someone talk about and then they would
like confirm it like they did all this
investigatory research it was like was
Tom extra rumor control was Tom Hanks
Tina to Chuck E Cheese snorting ritalin
off a piece of pizza are extra rumor
control got to the bottom of this and no
no he was not that's true really why'd
you say that if ik and they did all
these cool graphics I remember that
Hanks like snorting like dude nothing
although Robert by the [ __ ] guy Billy
yeah Billy
yeah now adays nowadays you can float
any story with detail and you know
you're gonna have a group of people that
are definitely watch I'm going I really
actually just tweet out whatever you
want that's what the Soviet that right
is bigger bigger and then people start
reaching the Russian they ordered a
bunch of fake stories during the
election yeah yeah and it came they they
isolated coming from from Russia an hour
and the other side like Trump picked up
on some of them and it's amazing man
they've always waited to decide again
same with
athlete if like some girls accuse them
of rape as soon as us being goes
whatever famous athlete uh you know
convict not convicted but accused of
assault it doesn't matter what happens
that I don't you already [ __ ] that's
right because the media is oh damn
dumbass all your sponsors its crew you
know gaining sexual like that like
sexual assault surrounding your your you
can just your whole reputation like what
Cosby did [ __ ] terrible right yeah
[ __ ] terrible
me my brother time about this one around
the road I forget to talk to us you guys
remember that you'll remember you all
fill you in
that guy sharper he's a safety for the
New Orleans Saints
I think the Green Bay Packers - but he
got accused of rape from 16 different
one oh yeah I remember this have you
ever say bring a vision he was chatting
it up with drug you know hold on it will
copy stuff yes same exact style oh yeah
but this dude is a dying piece and in a
trial they asked them like we don't get
it like we you were like yeah Darren
Sharper 20 years in prison break gang oh
yeah but check it out they asked him
during the trial ago we don't get it
like you were known as the biggest
ladies man in the world like
good-looking dude and why would you roll
baller captain the team richard is never
closed the deal those ankles no he have
so many girls and he goes it just got
too easy I didn't know what to go wrong
answer you Jesus I mean you know you
made it easier I feel [ __ ] drug women
yeah and I served I'm you know hey how
wouldn't your friend yet oh look at him
look good-looking you go but when your
friends be like hey [ __ ] face they
didn't know because y'all so many girls
like use the ladies look at this [ __ ]
dude up pro baller stud I've been to
club on a few no no any good-looking
dude you know - Gillian it an analyst -
analyst not anymore
anyone years in prison jail yeah 20 you
get 20 years while she lied to rent
Jersey just for your ass for the left me
I love that did you guys put that up for
me huh eyeliner I've been shot well
there you go 18 here like to apologize a
thousand times many a 16 women but they
say there's so many more oh God
keeps crawling down I'm still trying to
figure out why make some of these
choices I live life right for three
eight years I just took this path
shame and his voice thickened and broke
as he said raised now take such actions
do that yeah male hey hold on how this
18 so 18 year prison sentence fined
$20,000 for drug and raping will key now
go ahead and Jerry had a slap on the
wrist Wow
uh he's gonna have to do a lot of
lawsuits 20,000 that's like if you get
four questions deep on millionaire you
know that's true man that's pretty easy
to have easy as [ __ ] in the beginning
super easy so the one guy did get out
once on a super easy question has been a
bunch yeah
those are pretty much great there's one
guy one saw he gets on there and there's
Vieira's like man so you just got in and
like I heard you flew in late last night
as like yeah it's been crazy actually
haven't slept I just have like five cups
of coffee it's like well you're here now
and we're set let's do it you ready to
play is like yeah yeah I mean I'm super
tired but let's say let's do it like I'm
waiting for this like for a long time
like whatever and just like oh [ __ ] like
this is not going to end well I can
already tell and they started to do the
music and then I need some of the
greatest names by the way that's how
shitty like theme songs have just really
gotten like lazy like I mean think about
like Family Matters [ __ ] and even Cosby
like full house full house dude these
long way valid so melodic and then now
stale American Idol was just bring
that's right kind of court Spain yeah
you just had me do it let's go so this
kid gets on there and the question was
like you know some easy like this Sesame
Street character like really had a you
know loved cookies was it big bird
Cookie Monster Grover or you know Pete
Sampras you know and I just want to
crazy answer and the guys there's always
a crazy yet I cook yeah or the guy
behind you what psych major look we'll
be right back and uh which would be a
great way that's what I want to host
that show just do weird [ __ ] like that
elected that was never a part of Regis I
applied with you we'll be right back
just a commercial but there's no
commercial so everyone's just sitting
there like oh actually still playing Oh
live all right yeah well what's your
answer me yeah so he he's so tired he's
looking him over and he's just like hi
Cookie Monster go over a definite no he
was so tired that he was like doing a
thing we kind of reasons like Sampras
does like you know he does get spawn she
does like cookies I have to [ __ ] an
exampie says like cookies and then he
said like you know
big bird final answer and then just like
it looks they give them an out to die go
are you sure early and Shay emerge the
one you wanted and then they even title
me oh do you think the bird ate cookie
you think Cookie Monster is not the guy
here to go well cookie moths are not
appealing in any way at all
should I do 50/50 like it's early so
again those are the I mean it's the
whole thing democracy to you like see
some of these people want to show you
and God bless you
should have to we meet ya don't have
kids what does birthdays like we have
enough of that guy what is it like the
guy standing in line at Starbucks who's
like looking through the menu it's like
dude like tell me like if you never been
in a copy shop avoid she's like how many
liked and can you get like the the shots
like which sides is like the best side
not making that guy oh [ __ ] hate that
guy
I hate the guy that goes in front of
Langa's it I'm factoring is that drink
good because I've worked here they're
all [ __ ] good brides you [ __ ] right
either
will go I don't quite be at Burger King
like how's the fries here are they good
he's like [ __ ] Burger King man I
don't know I can i buy at the mall ride
by sneaker absolutely now I gotta buy
sneakers and I and as a nike dip and I
look at the guy and I go it's good
sneaker and he goes to great sneaker and
I went yeah he goes great support and I
look at him and I was like you are 50
pounds overweight you've never done a
[ __ ] I've never run on that I'd
you've never run a strike oh he's trying
to tell ya do and yet I'm like I go cool
right there you know there has a little
thing on yeah my credit card is for you
yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
it really is I've some of the ability
somebody tell me it's great dude I've
some of the [ __ ] that people have told
me sometimes just to get me I was
looking for a ping pong table once right
love ping-pong and wish I had more space
for a table now crushing to keep going I
have a table for real yeah it was
varsity named the time in the place
sounds like the place has been
established into place unless we don't
have welcomed us to go to a [ __ ]
Sports Authority
late-night ring in dick a wearing good
different that film it all we go to my
garage and I break out the ping-pong
table just as long he's no one thing and
I put
a lot of spin on the ball and if I'm if
it's forehand be ready for topspin and
stay way back if it's backhand slice NIT
okay and then get ready for the returns
because I grew up prepping against
backspin and was trained by uh-huh who
Andre Agassi graph yeah our cry and
Andre Agassi's dad who would Skype in
and throw [ __ ] more backspin Sunday
you're gonna have to deal with a super
physically fit 50 year olds backspin huh
and I'll be like you got it accent dad
so you were taught but I would caught by
on ten on one Alcala oh yeah not a real
guy though yes it is he was the dividend
three notices I had real coaches you
just had guys made up just now who was
it again huh yeah thank you
the guy so rare didn't exist got
coaching sounds it was known are
unorthodox they wanted real his name
must be hot whispered hey I feel like
there's two types of people pushing
College High School guys that played
ping-pong yeah I think guys it
definitely did it
yo well well guys that are proud of
their ping-pong game and those got my
money
yeah for sure I'm like pretty good I bet
guys just serve it good yeah don't
[ __ ] swing like you're actually
playing tennis cuz if you go do that go
play tennis man that's a playing ping
pong chop lotto strokes short have some
fun maybe drink a beer in between right
I do follow a B a little beer pong yet
thank you after like a couple games
really became a bowl game over at Fir so
I'm at this about Big Five Sports I'm
looking for right and I go to the guy go
hey man what's a which a good indoor
table and he goes we got some great
outdoor tables to go hell yeah let's go
back to that first question though when
I asked about the table that I matches
him for and he goes uh and he goes well
we've got this one over here and this
one's great he goes how much you looking
to spend
I go I don't know man like not a crazy
amount because it's a ping-pong table he
goes like five six hundred I go go ahead
and bring that down a little bit like
maybe like two three like him probably
find a good table for that unless it's
like super dope and you really sell me
on it and so he goes this table right
here was like 350 or so like that it
just like was real stored sturdy
whatever and and yeah I don't know how
to gauge it I was like going around the
sides making up things that were
probably like a reasonable I was like is
the table like does it always stay this
[ __ ] hard thousands come quest yeah
and then he says to me I go and what
about this one he goes are worse also a
lot of that
when he goes it's a weird [ __ ]
Selma's out I go oh [ __ ] and it's like
an October I go on it totally and I go
is October a popular ping-pong season
and he straight up verbatim goes bro
it's ping-pong season all the time
can I go I do the next thing you pointed
I'm in a box yeah that's how this is my
buddy my buddy keep on giving you this
any progress my buddy Jerry Burks
it's like on you know Gotham the best
the man the best you know oh yeah he's
the bad the greatest my best man oh my
god it would come like to that bar right
next door like drink and hang out after
the show he's a guy that a go oh let me
park your Bentley for you and scuff the
rims and I did that to you but but Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy Lera you may play ping-pong
you know he'll plant you at anything and
you guys good he was guys Oh BJ
ping-pong he just could Swiss Army
knives literally has everything so
really describe a person it's a guy he
gets to know yeah and the guy kind of
thin guy and he says would you play were
you an athlete he said I was a squash
player and a ping-pong player and Jimmy
goes much interesting I play ping-pong
and he goes oh yeah and he goes yes
would you ever would you play because
now I was competitive and played on a
national level
so Jimmy goes really well I would love
to play somebody that could and the guy
goes uh if i wouldnt want to play me and
he goes well I've been playing my whole
life and I absolutely would and he goes
yeah but I don't think I said I'm it's
you know you just not it's just a
different game yeah so Jimmy said well
how do you think I do and the guy said
to Jimmy said I mean I think that if we
played let's say six games I don't think
you would get a point and so Julia let
alone there's a lot of points out yes
hold on hi let's just say we play to 21
right that's that's a lot I get one yeah
that's a hundred twenty-six points
wherever it is so he goes um well uh I
don't believe that I think I could do
that because yeah all right
so they play six games in and get a
point
job at a job isn't that it's good for
people to hear that because people don't
realize like if you like I remember I
saw a professional bowler who's next to
us like guys watching me my friends pull
like some [ __ ] yeah like there might
be a strike one out of four for sure oh
the professor ball they don't miss oh
they are theirs
neither striker sphere even seems so
boring tato do not know Amos you're
gonna love this story
Matt my buddy got his black belt in
Taekwondo this is in Hoboken New Jersey
okay where I was living in Hoboken he
had just got his black belt in Jersey
and he we used to spar right and he goes
he goes I'm sparring the sky and I go
well who is he and he goes he's this big
black guy he played he played middle
line but he's a professional middle
linebacker play in the NFL he was a big
NFL fan I camera guy but he didn't play
long but he played in the NFL and middle
linebacker that's all I knew it I don't
know football and he goes and I go I go
well that's not good and I go what is
his fighting training he goes he was a
boxer he boxed for a long time I said
was he's it was he a pro and he goes I
don't know but I know he boxed you know
a lot I find out and I said I go Scott
you don't you can't spar that guy he
just goes bigger than me much go go go
that's not a good guy to spar right like
I thought I could just I don't know I
can tell you I don't like the fact that
he was a middle linebacker so any maldis
I mean NFL and he boxes I don't like
those I don't like that fat math you get
nervous and and he goes and I said I go
don't spar him I remember I never very
clear I go don't spar and he goes I'm
his bomb so long story short I wasn't
there but he said that he roundhouse
kicked the guy and the guy caught it and
then punched him in the ribs and broke
all the ribs on his I think was all the
Reds on his right alive huh in one
that's right but that's writing about
that guy's not even like saying a pro
you know like a profiling like as pro
experience right of athletics again I
think it's really short like pros vs.
joes great Sherman that didn't do it do
justice for us yeah some of it he gets
these double got it but like I remember
us playing Chris Anderson Birdman's a
friend of mine and really play
basketball and I'm like I'm just gonna
dunk it like I won't be able to get a
shot off
we played pickup basketball he was like
well why would I work on my like my
short I got like I'll say you put my
nuts in everyone's face yeah he
literally just stay at the top the
three-point didn't miss
shot just he didn't miss what dude did
miss one shot he's a pro he's a [ __ ]
pro as ever I mostly got to be way more
fun to do that when you're in the post
all the time so you like him who is that
a quarterback for before Eli Manning who
big guy 200 pounds per Giants the
quarterback Kelly Jim Kelly from Buffalo
no score who feel bad for the Jews
no yeah how long ago this was in
probably before he lie who is the
quarterback before you live in New York
yeah for a while he played for a while
big guy 50 pockets oh no no not
exercised for a while see they had a
condom the Giants before a waimea
question play for a while can you bring
that up chin or you know dead that
remember Lorenz from Kentucky the
300-pound quarterback they had him as a
backup
that's who referred out I was a PR move
the peel all day my man Josh Johnson did
Geno Smith now that's the current one go
to um uh yeah sure yeah listen you're
James Frank right
there we go ok ok ok ok
yes so Kerry Collins was playing a
pickup ball with Jimmy Burke and some of
the boys and and again they were playing
pickup they're playing touch football
with teams and he was just like it was
the craziest [ __ ] thing in the world
he would just view this drop back and
put the ball anywhere he needed to and
it was catchable
it was just being like you told you I
played uh I play the game of 21 and that
that really come story by the way of
course every story I could have quit
oh we touch football punch against you
guys you mean you threw the ball and hit
you in the numbers
I don't why this caller story yep you
know it's like it is like if they saw us
go on stage and was like wow every joke
you did crushed
yeah let me try that yeah right I am the
Kerry Collins it's comedy kids dropping
dimes it well I told that's why
basketballs Vinny Testaverde just a game
a 21 he was 50 he put his nuts in my
face I can nuts he dunked on me when
everyone by the way you shouldn't yeah
just make a coffee table book of I
played pick a pickup game with well
there's a lot done god there's only two
though I won't even 82 pages look yeah
six-six Vinitaly 565 Tanis [ __ ] cancer
over riches balls handsome invested in
fifty Outback steak houses for their big
dynamo Frankie now when you go into
video games you try to like you want to
win so that you can walk away the story
abut I just took it to Testaverde no I
so you can say I took it to Testaverde
everywhere you go I want to take it to
him he would have beat me he was so good
at Maskull yeah oh so many of those
athletes are just in a fitting way the
other sport like LeBron you've seen
videos of him like you catch a football
and throwing it like it's like oh yeah
you could do every sport
the thing about meet Ezra is he made us
watch the highlight tape of the 1998
Ravens and I think it's a two on one
Ravens team so we had to watch that for
like an hour and a half yeah we're just
showing a word so many highlighters of
myself yes Greg look what I used to do
exactly did you do any sport every sport
yeah I was the I mean I quit football
myself me er to play Danny Zuko in
Greece and that's what started the whole
[ __ ] pathway to like entertainment so
I did baseball football basketball all
grown up that's well as many sport you
know that's why I said about you know
being a Jew and not going pro obviously
there are other reasons like not being
like in 69 you know style or black yeah
or black yeah and I bet but I mean you
know said three-point records in my high
school I was dope I was a great high
school basketball player but there's a
sophomore year was that good to
sophomore year you were so well you
played although football till summer but
that's what all for all right
and yeah I mean if I was like 64 I
probably would have tried to like play
like some college like maybe a d2 or
some but it's like also I was doing you
know what I realized I was doing all
these sports and then senior year was
finally when I just dedicated everything
to basketball and it's like you can't
also be the best at something at that
age if you're not like the kids who were
dominant we're doing like basketball all
year round every time and maybe play
another sport yeah but I was kind of
spreading myself thin so you were also
doing like performance plays yeah I know
you know did you know like did a like
did a bulb go off after you did it like
you knew that yeah well it was like so I
did first played it was fifth grade to
play the Cowardly Lion in The Wizard of
Oz which if you ask my mom yeah you're
in the heat and yeah you got to
motorboat Sandra Bullock and yeah that's
great I love to bring that up at Temple
auctions because people want to know
what if they smell
you know and uh and I go peaches mom to
stay in touch with Kara
yeah good person hey you use grapes you
said you're in heat yeah
what were you lucky Oh word I thought
not at the Niro movie okay great by the
way people would say that when I would
you know I was obviously milked at
credit like right after that like they
say they say they say The Wizard of Oz
to a sixth grade and and people would
always go it was in heat and then I get
up there and like but sometimes address
it but that's what people like dude how
Punk an old are you yes like outsider
yeah judge they don't like Mike McCalla
got my part no kidding your way five
days for that [ __ ] roll got you all
sort of been so great that would have
been done between me and Michael
McDonald really and you're not sad about
it you'll figure it out Bobby line of
let it go
how would you [ __ ] question how was
ghost buzz how's the Civic toast but I
mean great it was the only downside was
that I mean it was all that was you know
Paul gave me a little thing in spy and
it was like you know I remember I put
myself on tape after the heat for a
couple bigger roles and he was like oh
he's like man thanks this one's going to
Bobby Cannavale a and this one's going
to Melissa's husband and I was like yeah
yeah but also like just you know let me
know I come in and maybe dude be like
their backup like I can say some of
their lines with them and he's like nice
outward and and so he's like but L yeah
there's this thing it's like three lines
if you want to come out to Budapest for
a week and just do that and I was like
yeah I just want to stay in your you
know camp and then uh so same thing with
ghostbusters and it was just cool to be
I mean just being on a movie set is the
greatest been like and having more how
that movie do and he did really well I
mean I don't think what fake is amazing
could man the critic rahama station
fence and the critics I think it didn't
maybe make what they thought it was but
a joke and all that [ __ ] from some
[ __ ]
yeah made all I want them because the
issue with the movie is it was you know
you talking about Bill Murray dan
Aykroyd currently male moving away this
2017 yeah all women now outside he goes
well now all right yeah I mean that
summer Terminator she does sad he's like
oh [ __ ] haha are we do it yeah yeah say
yes
like well I don't want my Terminator
with tips like we we don't have to do
that yeah so you were anti girl
Ghostbuster uh give me [ __ ] Bill
Murray and Dan Aykroyd don't [ __ ] with
it
if you can make it classic you better
make do it well so I get going the
complete opposite direction totally and
Kristen Wiig and all them are burial
hilarious and I I didn't see the movie
right because I don't want to remember
it like that and I'm gonna totally get
that
yeah funniest movie one of the funniest
movies is a kid I've ever seen and
stripes and ghostbusters to me I
remember enjoying ghostbusters so much
that I when I'm really really loving
something I can't even laugh I was
biting my nails and just so astonished
as a young man is how [ __ ] good it
was yeah like I Bill Murray made me
laugh I mean they are so movie with yes
oh good yummy
it was side strike like redo it why
would he do it I'll say yeah lassic
Harold rain did you have fun on it was a
great I mean like I hit on the mood for
five minutes no you were great yeah well
the part that I had to I mean did like
the voice of Slimer which was like you
were the voice I'm yeah yeah but I mean
it was even that was there was way there
was a - more like slammer scenes and
they got chops but it was a I knew Paul
wasn't gonna didn't need anybody famous
for that you know it's like they need
like Morgan Freeman to be like you know
I'm Slama you know so I was like how did
you do however have five well sure I'll
show you in a minute and I so I was like
Paul doesn't need and also I knew he
wasn't thinking of me for it so I bought
the slammer masks online and and that
had the face cut out and I made this
like fake audition tape to send so I was
like hey what's up I'm Slimer as my
audition tape for ghostbusters I did the
first two I don't know right I really
have to [ __ ] do this but whatever I'll
play the game and as I did a bunch of
things of like I did the actual voice a
few times so I could do it and I did a
bunch of like fakes and I was like
here's Slimer you know at a funeral
hitting on a chick and then it would be
a quick Vantage okay and then I jumped
out like max honey like slammer waking
up realizing he overslept he was become
the other class you know and just oh
[ __ ] you know they just come cut to that
a bunch of those - then also be fun as I
said as long as I assume until I said to
him and then he email mean so when you
come to ADR for the thing and then I
went in open the binder that said slam
or whatever news
yeah just do it I was super pumped but
it was you know I mean the voice it was
just you know I mean when I did it
actually Michael McDonald I'll say I did
was like a it was like like see like
that yeah I remember I did that Michael
McDonald [ __ ] I know I know how it looks
like when you eat [ __ ] I'm very funny
yeah and but no the movie was cool but
the scene I was in got chopped way down
because it was this big rock star I was
a rock star at this concert the first
time they catch a ghost it was the
middle movie like huge set-piece scene
it was like a 10 day shoot and they had
me I had maybe 15 lines and like singing
these two songs and like they shouted
like all these extras let me feel like a
true rock star like Comedy Jam is one
thing this was [ __ ] nuts and like
Paul - the comfort level he was like yo
like letting the Improv just so much and
I felt comfortable to do it like on the
heat it was like first thing so I was so
nervous to say anything because I was
like pockets like Bullock and McCarthy
think they don't laugh at something I
say like that's it you know and and so I
would get attacked by the ghosts and
then they had a stunt guy and I was
supposed to get like they pulled him off
the stage and one move up into the air
then they put me in this thing upside
down and like swung it back and forth
and twist around and they had me I sang
all these lines as I was upside down
like you know hanging over people then
dropped into the crowd and then get up
and then more lines and climb back
onstage with all that got chopped
because of times nothing like there's
like four shots of me singing and like a
couple lines and then getting attacked
it's cool to like you know it's still
[ __ ] cool man
what happens with everyone like Jared
Leto's talking about the other day in
the interview when he did a Suicide
Squad Lee I just saw he's brilliant as
the Joker and he's so he's like he's
what you go better than you
what's up not better than he was
different yeah different cool [ __ ]
good but Divya and he's use upset Cleo's
I shot all these scenes man I thought
I'll be the hit of a movie and he goes
you could have made a movie just on
Joker heroes and I'm sitting that's
premiere he's like what the [ __ ] is
wrong literally like what is this I
don't have that Jitlada yeah that's your
dad yeah that man will do all day they
cut you down and then while editing is a
art in its own I know like its reach out
in the story yeah same makes it like the
movies written when it's three times
when it's written when it's shot and
want to hide your show right man
oh man hey by the way nothing you should
know in social America we're dating
feels weird by the way what a great way
to announce a relationship everybody Lea
yeah everyone the clasp and then the
song Iran we're doing we're doing to
remake a Brokeback Mountain to me way
better we're gonna call Edition you just
see this to do date did you t we go
through an advantage to Korea weird it
is crazy how many things you like they
can chop down a movie like well I did I
did six days on steel magnolias and and
they were like yo like you know you're
gray like you're carrying the movie like
obviously Julia Roberts is in it I don't
know oh wow okay yeah and also that was
a long time ago yeah
when was it only in the movie I have a
few to remember the scene when she walks
in she's like Shelby Shelby you know and
then there was some [ __ ] super
attractive young care they were like I
was just kids 12 what is dicks like
bursting through his pants I'm at work
might be 17 okay watch the DVD extras
walking through in there and he says I a
Julia you know and they're like he would
call the characters the real names and I
get Shelby and he's like [ __ ] I do
what I want you know no I don't remember
this okay
well yeah because it got cut out okay
I'm trying to save my story alright
sorry Wow all right well what angle
magnolias all right open your heart in
your mind
I accept of me it's I'm making boner
sound effects it does look good but did
you use comedy like you stand up your
passion or is acting great question oh
look if you had to pick one I came here
to act and like you know now like this
there's a showman right now call bird
you know joy McIntyre from New Kids on
the Block yeah you betcha
yeah so you guys had me and on he's the
[ __ ] incredible dude so he's got the
show they created like Kirby enthusiasm
he's kind of 30 rock about his life post
pop star it's on this network called pop
TV that's everyone's 8:30 and it's I
play as manager and it's meet him
January Jones David Koechner Joey Joey
Lawrence yeah I mean yeah the best toy
Fatone was on for a little bit him
so that's the first though show that
I've been on like you know this game
show for TBS with Eliza MADtv and some
movies but like this is like the first
showed I've been in where I'm like an
actor you know I'm saying like on it and
like consistently in what
I've been on the air since 2001 I mean
10 years postgraduate in 2005 and so
that was like that was the game plan but
then I think like anything you just have
to like adapt my whole thing was I want
to do as much as possible I did a lot of
YouTube videos in college and then
afterwards when YouTube really hit and I
was like just a big love for sketching I
remember I even like Brian you were the
best I mean before I barely even knew
you and sent you like a thing of being
like remember like singing like a bunch
of videos and like some pilot then I was
like can you give me some advice in like
the [ __ ] greatest dude in the world
like maybe it you know had la jolla and
maybe a couple other conversations and
just sends me this [ __ ] long email
and then goes you know what actually
call me and gives me like a whole
rundown of like usually should do do
this like keep doing this like felt like
it was very encouraging which is like
invaluable you know Mike I had to do my
job to look up to somebody like and have
them actually go other way it was a was
huge and so uh but I mean like so I
found stand up and you know YouTube
videos were helping me to like you know
get a comedic voice but also you know
keep busy because it was like I graduate
from su in the theatre degree and it was
like alright now what like worked at
Universal Studios playing Wolverine and
being a tour guide for like a long time
yeah well 23 bucks an hour to do
Wolverine so not a bummer
what it was a bummer cause you know when
went on there and I want to instead
here's my question I did that tour yeah
and as you go around and you see you go
to the Bates Motel yeah and he comes
walking with you with a knife okay 20
bucks an hour like 12 did he do that he
does that over and over and I'm that guy
what's he doing and the guy who plays
like he just as weird as you think he is
and how long did you do that for I was a
tour guide my sophomore year at SC for
two years and then the pay was crap but
it was like you know five hour-long
towards a great stand-up training great
leg and you had real jobs in life like
you didn't yeah you were like you learn
to work ethic oh yeah my mom well like
what was my mom was like y'all hope you
get a piece-of-shit car I know is my you
know what does my mom and I compliment
you because when I saw you I hadn't seen
your standup in a long time I'm sorry
when you were a young guy that's Ryan
stuff you're all it's funny haven't seen
him since we know probably when I was
when you let me open for you a couple of
times I'm annoyed yeah that was what 10
years ago I've been doing it almost 10
so maybe like seven okay so seven
because when I saw you that night at in
Austin yeah it was legit
okay it was [ __ ] we were dying and I I'm
talking I was rain my brother were they
were howling holidays and I was watching
and kind of going man Adam is really
like that kind of work ethic has
produced an excellent comic oath and I
don't say that lightly because you knows
what I do there are a lot of people that
just float by with [ __ ] they wrote five
years ago or they're a lot of people
being charming and comfortable on stage
and not that they don't write and so to
see like legit comedy it's like Tony Ken
same thing [ __ ] kill him yeah because
Tony works his ass off yeah and Tony's
like I'm going to try to be the funniest
person I could possibly beat up and I
that's my that's my philosophy
yeah not be cool just try to make us
laugh as hard yeah you can't I mean it's
why this job is so like unique like you
can't replace all that actual work and
and once I you know I was dating this
girl for a little bit and in 2007 when I
started and we broke up I was like
because I was very in and out I was
doing some like groundling stuff and I
was doing stand-up like twice a month I
like to bring her shows and I was like
alright if I need to like so if I'm
going to do this right I have to go all
in but I kept holding back because I
knew what it required and it was like
very intimidating and then when she and
I broke up I will actually she cheat on
me she [ __ ] the camera in Reno she was
a news reporter
anyway but what was I must and so uh and
she told me I don't know it's comedy
told me and she she goes and I was like
wait so it was the guy that shot all
your stories and I made this joke over
the phone I go did you shoot them in
your face cuz grunge is less so
emotional of course you lab she's like
why'd you say that I was like I don't
know how to do that analyst out there
you know say you asked all these
questions any question in your face I
know I told that I talked to guys I feel
like right you know we have similar
circles yeah you know all that I told
Brad like someone told I don't know how
your sir but I told Brad Mike I don't
think Adam likes me he's like I want to
you know some point I do because I'm
like I was like yeah you said that what
we're doing about what we're doing it's
not happening yeah
and I saw y'all on Mike what did here's
much meat no here's my thing I'm a huge
fan of you this podcast and I you know
that was the first time I met you know
bright and loved bright forever and so
being a fan of the podcast I'm like I'm
like knowing I'm like all right someone
I'm gonna run into Brendon and hopefully
it's you know before I get a chance
maybe come on the show and then we
walked in I was like all right like and
it was in this
tiny little hallway which is a weird
place to meet somebody because your
handshake it's funny like shoving your
nose to nose he's [ __ ] like towering
over me I'm like I didn't want to
mmediately be like I love to show you're
great man you know like so it's just
like what's up and like but also trying
to play it cool yeah and like I feel
like I know you from the podcast like
having had a face-to-face yeah so that's
why maybe you saw no weirder that was
before I think also I like Pokemon the
ass when he walks away and that might be
the thing we like this guy's like no I
encouraged oh okay
well I'd be like righto bro yeah yeah so
it was weird because that whole night
was because Joey Diaz have an issue with
me cuz he didn't but yeah we did a whole
show on it so joy Diaz with me and then
I knew you were gonna be then someone
told me that may be an issue Lisa Mike
that's a good dude I don't hate I know
welcome Brian Brian was out of town so
I'm like soul Obama zone so I rolled out
like what's up everybody and I just I'm
not super real hard dude no you're great
yeah I've done I got no hate my heart
unless me there's a couple people from
high school that camera
okay that camera man you know so funny
when I met him I went out to Reno right
she we went to USC together and then she
got a job at the page program at NBC so
she's in New York like you know working
that's no parties no stuff and it'd be
like late night cause that's when I
really started saying too because I was
like I can't sit around waiting for
these phone calls from her I need to be
out of the club distracting myself
because then I'd be home sometimes she's
like bedtime I'm like rushing to SNL
party John Stamos is here I gotta go bye
he and not even hearing in the
background be like okay but you know
sometimes they hang people you know some
moment but what is a mostly I call back
what do you say about your buddy
you know didn't say anything and it
wasn't bad guy said it yeah if I can put
it on the hang-up and my where are you
come back you notice I just had to get
out of the house and and so then she got
a job in Reno we're like oh great now
she's closer like and as a news
reporting job and it works still like
not a huge market but for her to get
that job like that early was was a big
deal now like it's an hour flight and
then she just got super bummed out
she one from LA to New York big cities a
lot of fun you know you mean over all
the [ __ ] Reno let's just sit on that
for a minute with that sink in if you
haven't been to Reno lovely city going
there in may to the laugh at you come
out and see me
but yes City [ __ ] sucks the river is
kind of cool but that's about it
pump to go on that River and then also
pluck and try to not kill myself
fact but also come out of the shows may
I don't know a gym a 30 sec my website
or my tv.com 318i taco so I go out there
to visit her and all the is like married
couples are all older she's like hot 24
year old young news reporter and
remember the only guy who was like close
and age range was 30 year old camera man
named Jeff and I swear they got I go out
there and I and I'm like a bad-looking
dude but for sure you're like nah man in
a way like oh wait
Jeff I remember when I shake every hi
Jeff dude i straight up member shaking
his hand and he goes what's up man I'm
Jeff and I was just like you knew you're
gonna [ __ ] her you knew just knew man
and then she got super like depressed
because she was so like lonely and I was
like open I was like baby you just got a
like come out and stay with me for LA
for a little bit and refigure out what
your move is because you're miserable
there and this is not good then your boy
just said what's this would you like
Jeff was here shoulder in line or a
digna suck on a sound guy you see the
camera well no he's doing both he
doesn't both gaze camera guy he goes
what's his boom like it's my dick
talking to my dad obviously neighbor
talking what if he did that though and
they would go and she'd always tell me
to check named Jeff and I take up in a
mountain and there was a fire say to go
up and cover the fire and like track for
a while and I'm like oh hell yeah
okay so anyway okay - I was thinking
about [ __ ] plan out there killing
both you what's going on here anytime
you hear about that with you mean you're
hanging out with them [ __ ] you guys
are guys like your boyfriend's in LA and
- who are trapped in this but I was game
on Reno mountain yeah like this rock art
camera guy boulder yeah let's figure it
out really iPhone they breaking new suck
this yeah yeah you know you know right
away but that was the end of so anyway
long story short that once that stopped
I was like all right now I have no
reason to jump into stand-up full-time
and make that and then to your earlier
question about stand-up or acting I
think they go hand in hand
obviously right they're synonymous like
really begs the different but I feel
like I mean what's crazy is I always
thought I was going to start samples
like now acting is still like amazing
that's why I came out here for and then
it's like you get into that grind
stand-up and like I mean it's like I you
know I feel so fortunate that I have
like put the work in and at least emit a
cool place where I get to do some cool
things now but like you know there's so
I mean it never stops and like the
challenge and the grind of it is like
never
that's like a painting you're never
gonna finish solely and I'm not allowed
people get to have that thing that's
constantly where you're like oh it's
never done and like it's all on you too
I mean you know even at Austin I mean
there were shows those on and I felt
good on some of others I'd see some
people in like [ __ ] man I get back to it
at night and even like try to flesh out
some jokes that I was not thinking about
doing that I was like I'm gonna do them
now because I saw something that really
inspired me and to be inspired like you
know that often is pretty cool I mean
obviously we watch so much of it that
you know I think sometimes you just have
the blinders on and you're like not
another comic but like to every now and
then like see you know Chappelle or
Buraq Allen you know if I can just
deliver that seriously man you know it's
it's and then to become friends with
people like that and be on the shows and
then you just makes you want to raise
your game and for sure but I mean a
therapist you're you're part of a very
exclusive fraternity - yes and the rush
of that like I mean the rest of a great
I mean I don't know again I think they
are maybe different but I mean my I
don't know Pat me I
acting's what got me and all this
performing was that [ __ ] because it does
it cure your performance it could stand
up you know that's why I starts Dana
because I was doing so much theater and
when I graduate I was like I did one
play after college which was super fun
but then I was like and I loved being on
stage too and so I was like oh I need
that live fix and so that's why stand-up
any case my role is a little bit too
totally and it's all on you and it's
like when I was trying to do improv and
stuff I was having so much trouble
getting a group together to like
rehearse or put you know practice and
also like stand up to like it like
you're investing yourself and also it's
not like casting directors don't know
sorry just not right for the part yeah
well this is my business like right you
have your business your your business
you constantly a destination totally and
the life skills I'm like I'm sure like
you guys can both attest to this like
stand-up just makes I feel like so much
like it parties if I'm in a [ __ ]
conversation that sucks like I can I can
take control of it and make sure it's
not gonna be a bummer or figure out how
to get out of I never feel like socially
inadequate or awkward I mean you know
everybody has you know the moment like I
was on a flight a few weeks ago and
there's a guy behind me got in a fight
with the flight attendant because
somebody ordered the last cheese plate
he [ __ ] flipped out I got super like
uncomfortable like just for everybody on
the plane also for him because he he
sound you know sometimes you're on a
plane and you hear some voice behind
you and yours like at some point I'm
gonna have to turn around to see what
that's attached to after this guy was is
just talking
it's kind of like there's and he had
like a little bit of a almost like a you
know that Greg Grover like Muppet like
it was dr. Phil with a throat fungus Wow
okay so that's the end of that story
okay well I thought it'd be a good segue
into Carnival it's going to yeah so I've
got Jim taking you guys off track of it
all man I want to do her Stern event
ESPN will cut 100 on-air personalities
that's not why I'm today no way I've
heard a few have you seen all the guys
doing cut like Trent Dilfer
the great one is homeboy here ed Werner
you can't cut Edward or all of them got
Kuwait this is it this can't be real
it's real really look at all these guys
being like um no I I saw this auto
scroll down [ __ ] that's my favorite they
gonna get rid of Peter ok this is my
favorite where's that keep going
I got explosive not to pass it it's so
funny oh no hit no keep going oh my go
play oh here it goes Mike Goodman goes
today's gonna suck for a lot of people
you skin it doesn't seem like too much
last rumor that those people are in fact
people scroll down and hey turns out on
one of those people is me
that's my cousin yeah yeah the other
things you suck for a lot of us being
real there's still people ah
turns out on one of those people what
luck you guys why on the [ __ ] ass
that's that Mike from know not Mike Mike
I don't know so so what what happened
why well from what I've heard is they're
they're focusing on the digital space
and also sports is that right yeah what
a bummer different than everything else
on appeal is getting trend Oprah's like
god dammit what do you do if you're not
it when you work in each panel your
on-air personality that's what you do
like know these guys go and that's time
to start that band of a legend wonder
you well some out like how to play the
triangle oh please don't join the hall
and oh they didn't tell them they just
showed a by the way do you think they
did in a tweet or a mass email or they
hold a special sports and where they go
can in it terrified that did they cut
those - cool - they must have right it's
just oh no did they don't say no this is
the show they're saving sport well
that's
Ford Center late night in LA though
scroll down John Holliman you can't get
rid yes Vienna's losing millions of
subscribers according to the latest
estimates Geoffrion has lost 12 million
subscribers in last six years about 12%
drop there's no sign of decrease loan
it's my favorite Network man why don't
think they're dropping what's happened
they have to maybe too much content yes
because my yet that's my religion like I
grew up on ESPN that dude I mean what
were dude I got a competitor like what's
getting more play always get more I
think they're just like did you just get
in there media elsewhere it's happened
to everyone like so first take on ESPN
gets I don't know something like 800,000
views in the morning will to Fox they
get like a hundred thousand like there's
no foxes in close to its like close to
sports areas peon do I did so he is
being growing up and feeling like I'd
watch it all the time it's my religion
and and then when they needed a UFC
analyst they caught like is being called
me my other way so they fly me to
Princeton him Jay Crawford my favorite
they drive the climate Bristol and you
know it's there's no preparation at all
she got a suit on you miked up have fun
like well do we want to go over some
notes and so I'm sitting in the Sports
Center chair and then Jake rocks it
sound like holy [ __ ] I'm on sports day
right now closeness with Jay Crawford
and no one's we've got haven't gone over
anything so it's just how they roll you
better be good at your job like that I
think that word that I can you know I'm
gonna talking about fighting and you
figured it out right
well Jacobs like now what you what guys
I was bringing down Cain Velasquez vs.
Werdum
yeah and he goes what what's four do
more Cain Velasquez what are they
feeling right now I'm like well Jace I
grew up your entire life watching
SportsCenter next thing you know you're
hosting and no one's done over a me sing
with you first hear a fire Hanson hey
kool-aid alright you know that I dude
like he plays with a little bit like I
and then I have to handle fire together
right answer pretty good spot on he
should have roll with that it was just a
user and I came back a second time dude
coaster but you know and that's probably
why ESPN is dropping because they're not
yes ending more comedic moments like
that it's like war and it's not because
I they let me co-host it
it could try to get up to you know start
when we had be Straub Island he just
started with big brown next curtain how
crazy is that man alright next kind of
in it you guys know this guy I didn't
watch The Bachelor but the bachelor
season nine I think it was 2015 he was a
star of it and I remember him he was in
a crash and he killed the John Deere
tractor driver that was in front of them
and then he fleed to lead the scene
oh there's a well-known oh he's [ __ ]
almost celebrity but he did actually
call 9-1-1 yeah and he was actually
feeling the guy's pulse to tell the
operator that he's still alive and then
he just took off why would he
what a [ __ ] he they found alcohol in
his car so I think that's the reason why
he do tell you to do that now do tell I
hate to tell you this compartment you
body colours lawyers like listen if they
can prove your drone he wouldn't come
out of his house up yeah when
commander's house either way so what's
gonna happen oh yeah we did I end up
movie careers over
now if I was you will not be on the
bathroom you know yeah if they're if the
alcohol if the alcohol goes through his
body and he can see he John Jones did
this there's a lot of you know really
white John John's fled the scene you can
tell you were just combines right I
don't know and this this but if they can
prove you're under the influence your
penalties so much more happen show he
hit the guys truck and the guy died in
this truck know so the the
tractor-trailer flew off into a ditch
and then he died there
and he hit distractor yeah why wasn't
get why was guys driving a tractor on
the freeway anyone brought this up he's
from the town I forgot what it was it's
like a it's a really like a farm town
they're like my only bottom lines
whatever you get away with you have to
deal with the fact that you drive if he
did if you did that you drank and took
someone's life
you still like she's mopey hardly the
scene to so have they caught up yet yeah
they got a murder he's gone wrong what
was the 911 call was he like apparently
with him saying like you know the guys
the guys still alive but barely hanging
on and then he just I bet he still had
an ego was he like he I hit this guy's
like who is it's Chris awesome from The
Bachelor whoo-hoo come on May mom's all
right I'm an allegiance season 7
everyone thought was end up with
Christian I went with Michelle people
are talking about it actually the guy
before he almost died was
like you should have gone with Michelle
it's so [ __ ] up man terribly long
felony dude drinking and driving is no
joke well especially when you take
someone's life who's probably math
father or whatever especially when you
sound super bummed ups but did on Good
Morning America I saw a thing where said
there's been more wrecks now because
people under the influence of drugs than
alcohol there's more deaths and car
accidents they for possible deals as a
drug I'm not sure but senseless or
texting is bigger than drinking a body
might just told me a girlfriend is was
crossing the street in New York and
texting just facedown dude I mean isn't
that crazy it's not cuz I see it all the
time I don't see people get hit but I
see people crossing the road like this
I'm like it's that's a red light to
whatever this person is Texan to all you
are [ __ ]
hahaha is your last thing or maybe you
were googling my doctor feels real
height and then [ __ ] up a little okay
some - boy - fibronectin
we hang with us she Hudgens
this guy's [ __ ] uh I've never heard
about this but have you guys heard about
this something called stealth thing what
we call Oh delving so yeah it is all
about this this is under her great
condom during sex like in the beginning
of sex you put the condom on and then
during sex you're a little bit home on
oh yeah break it John do we [ __ ] do
that or you just use a condom or you
don't I don't know variants like this
were somebody I know said then he pulled
it off during sex and she flipped out on
him and I was like whoa hey [ __ ]
yeah you dumb [ __ ]
Jesus we didn't want you have sex with
her without a condom and you belong in
what I had well I kind of get her
flipping out about that that's like a
magician like doing a trick and then
halfway through just being like man [ __ ]
it I got a condom on no is that look
yeah but this is beneath isn't like
breaking news I know guys have been
breaking condoms like oh it broke well
you'll figure it out oh man but usually
they say it's rape the girl all right
come back yeah but it is rape because
it's not consensual right yeah because
they thought you're doing
that is inherent in the act is evident
for the time it's not called removing
your economy intercourse and chatting
about why you want to do this yes I
would agree to have sex under one set of
conditions yes nothing for a reason
tally the punishments for Stellar's
appear minimal stall changing I really
lost care letter that it's rape well
this is having been posed but let's talk
about this because I could understand
somebody not I don't think it's rape I
mean let me say what I think it is the
victim consented to touched by a condom
not touched by skin of a penis the law
is clear that one may consent to one
form of sexual contact without providing
blanket future consent to all sexual act
I wouldn't want to be a lawyer in this I
do I will say this I think that if you
do that it I don't look like oh [ __ ]
here's where here's what I worry D
here's where I worry about with rape
okay here's what I worry about when we
start throwing rape around rape rape
it's like what bill burr was saying
about hero rape should be reserved it's
a very very strong word okay rape should
be reserved for you know having sex with
somebody against their will
right there's no wiggle room with the
term right like you're a whole side down
and forcing your dick inside of them
they don't have any sexual intercourse
there you go they both agree to have
sexual intercourse and not hotter those
rule right now that rate right so now is
it with she agreed to have sex with you
if you work on them you didn't use a
condom now that does that puts her at
risk for mostly certain pregnancy and
certain venereal diseases probably not
AIDS and and because it's oh but let's
just go through it but you you could get
chlamydia you could get herpes herpes
you get a lot of [ __ ] a little war
committee that could cause issues later
on and even AIDS and very very mean yes
likely so I man I don't know I'm not
ready it's not right it's [ __ ] up it
should be illegal but it's like it but
it's pretty cool it's like a notch down
like you're like I mean rapists are
higher so that's how do you define that
if it's not rape like well you all that
like you
I think rape is too strong a word for it
I really I think it's one of the people
she's in a word rape I think then then I
don't know what rate then it brave is
that big a broad umbrella term and if
you're talking about the fact that it's
really a question of whether and
a rubber or skin is coming into contact
with your skin I think that's a very
dicey area that's a really thin margin
the sunray it is too gray it is more
black than what it is oh man I mean the
part about them a little bit like raying
and then and then him and then you know
but you play under different rules right
Tuesday agreed to have consensual sex
under protection it's like what's this
what am i my friend Rick he raped the
situation and not her is that he plus
2c2 like I feel like rape is a part of
the like I think you can't just not like
that word is gonna make its way into
this situation somehow right I don't
know man
well you know making her go save the
bully just won't have sex if you don't
have a condom and some guys want to be
won't do that either yeah if they
wouldn't have had sex without a condom
and then you kind of just stealthily
took the condom off during sex it's kind
of tricky right it is it's anything to
do in a way it's a rapey tendencies buts
not ready there you go it's rapey
tendencies yeah like if a guy's being
wary oh don't be raped would they say
that in court I mean if we're chilling
Emily you're putting somebody's health
at risk right yes and your your what if
you're clean and and you and what liquid
what about this what if you're clean and
you had your tubes tied so she can't get
pregnant in your clean it's a good
question just don't think that you need
the physical holding down for to be he's
all have to do this right like that well
if she's under the influence and she
can't protect herself that's right -
yeah
there's dip but still if she's passed
out yeah so if you penetrate a girl and
she said no or she can't say no verbally
then that would be rape but if she's a
freak she's like we could do whatever
you want you in the whole Eastern run a
train just make sure you have condoms on
and the one that times brakes like oh
hell no tomfoolery here's my problem
with the drunk right here lieutenant if
you're drunk and you're making out on a
dance floor in yeah then you're then you
go to a little quiet corner and you're
like you know getting even heavier
grabbing each other and stuff you guys
are three steps and you go up to your
room your frat room whatever you're a
college kid and you're drunk as [ __ ] and
you start having sad
and she's completely [ __ ] obliterated
yourself and you're a little [ __ ] up -
I'll consider that rape and she wakes up
no wakes up nice one goes what the
[ __ ] I do goes what did i do she goes
I didn't agree that I use like I don't
remember that well that's right no
what's not fair you were drunk no yeah I
was drunk cuz you could ruin somebody's
life and it's not fair it's just not but
I have to say that when you pull the
condom off Bourbon that's bad I'll leave
it this way it's bad I leave in June
Orvil but it's not rape now I don't
think so either ap tendencies like was
he and then what is this guy is it one
case here we're just talking about like
no this should happen shouting time that
was just like is this like a fit like
you know how like there's a story a few
years ago about kids getting [ __ ] up
by butt chuggin they pull that cough
syrup into their ass something or
alcohol yeah sounds like a Jay Leno
headlines Lannisters always know our end
who did and that came in when I feel
like is just kind of on the same lines
or was just like becoming it just as
it's been happening for a while doing
the new sex trend that's not new leopard
also dolls were a trend when you're
described like trend and then rape like
this is the not a good headline
I only know if one guy was done this I
I'm new visually you know but I remember
my friend app playing dumb and I looked
at him I go stop playing dumb yeah
you're being a [ __ ] here for you she
found out and and he played me a message
she left and she said on a message she
goes it's not rape but it's pretty
[ __ ] close there is I see that's fair
yeah
yeah she said that I remember that and I
went like you know dude she's right
maybe she was given dumb back you know
what you were doing
don't look around like you didn't know
what the [ __ ] he would do also a few
maybe he was I mean you know if you're
trying to like prove to yourself that
you [ __ ] got quick hands like do that
like do a YouTube tutorial over like
look how fast I can if I can take it all
up but don't do with a woman because
then you're gonna get like curricula for
the [ __ ] what was unable to model it
a would that be like said unless it's
not a condom he hated a condom right so
you want to have a father yet but then
you know didn't to get [ __ ] your hand
you know you don't need a comment for
that is that take you right back it's
not taking something wrong belong to you
was it is that the equivalent of taking
something that doesn't belong to you
what does she never said you could do it
without a condom right for sure how that
you could penetrate her she agreed to
let you pet her
with with uh with a protective membrane
yeah it's tough right I don't know I
even Wanda that makes me science argued
Tommen's also on a whoever said they
don't particularly sales there's ninety
nine percent yes but she and she did
make you wear a common right what
percentage they agreed to a conscious
she's gonna say yeah I don't want to
said if you come at her without economy
she's going no way no way get a condom
and I will what do you think about this
you're a woman let's let's get a woman's
point of view illness and be honest
you're not to be politically correct and
you can totally diss already know is
listening you can disagree with it hard
don't worry about it I said no I don't
know I think that's [ __ ] up because
that's right if she says yes only with a
condom you're you're going against what
she's doing have you consider it rape a
no I don't think so so a Canadian that I
taught her a yeah that's right wait rape
a you don't you don't think so soft down
low a little bit rape I think it's like
the step below rate so sexual assault
cuz rape I think rape is really serious
sexual assault have you ever heard of a
guy doing this no I haven't why I'm not
surprised that it happened so I have
guys being guys am i right no guys
appreciate it it's a percentage I mean
this stuff like sucks cuz you're like
man like you know gives us all never do
this yeah there's look there's a lot of
shitty dudes but there's a lot of good
dudes and this is a little pretties
we're forked dude yeah man am i right
looks like we're doing pretty good so I
worry my young men I worry about young
men who are drunk and slunk and horny
and get and then they're like but but
you can't have any better principle have
to talk about it a lot of young guys
listen to this
on this podcast and it's an older guy
got a I gotta say yes don't [ __ ] do
this man because if you do it you're
being asked um I don't know a lot of
guys do that if you I think we ought to
give the main time edited out I didn't a
real quick it's not a trend so everyone
really it's not a dry good those guys
aren't doing very good for most guys who
listen to this show or like of course
that's [ __ ] we don't need a public
announcer and this is wrong no don't
make laugh you're right oh my god didn't
seem dumb I don't make your right trend
let's move on you're right well that's a
good example of how the media says it's
a trend in your [ __ ] right well I
think most eyes are
what yeah well they even talk by this
llamas for 30 minutes it's clearly
[ __ ] up trend is like you know oh
people are starting to wear rollerblades
to the roller skating rink you know
alright let's go to the next okay man
we'll be right back to the debate with
only whatever what else your chin on a
good note on lighter note Facebook is
talking about working on technology to
read minds and individual actually real
he took a personal ad okay I'm flying
car too crazy well that's going to help
people it's going to help if you read
minds you know the guys that are
breaking comments on purpose yeah V full
circle yep full circle gals well they
got optical neuroimaging already which
is where they'll show you a picture and
a certain part to your brain light up
that are familiar with familiarity it
means oh you've been in so you didn't
rob that bank
alright let's say a picture of the
inside of the safe and if your brain
lights up with a certain way they're
like wait a minute now there's a dark
side to this too because they try to
have racial they're there is um there's
this these neuroscientist came up with
this idea well if you are if you see
somebody who's black and you're white
and certain parts your brain lights up
there are certain areas of the brain
that can be led lit up when you have
negative feelings or impulses uh and and
so they were trying to do some people on
NPRM are talking about how we should
have all cops take this test I hate it
because it's actually [ __ ] science
because in fact that's not the case your
brain lights up a lot of times when you
see something that's not familiar with
you yeah that can also be sort of
something that you're that you don't
have positive feelings about but it's
unfamiliar so as a human brain you tend
to be you act with suspicion of things
are not as familiar right so you have to
be careful with that [ __ ] so you
know the mind mind reading is very very
dicey it's very like lie-detector tests
they're really good they work very well
apparently but guess what we don't have
they're not admissible in court for a
reason well guess what the psychics off
tennis boardwalk are pretty [ __ ] good
oh yeah the sidekick there's also
there's a woman who used to do the
psychic reading she charge ten dollars
she lived race live off of Lybrand
Melrose and was like ten dollars like
you're claiming you can read people's
[ __ ] Minds like ten dollars like what
does
like I can see you very hungry I came in
with a [ __ ] sandwich but like these
people I feel like they if they're going
to do it like use it for use it for good
stuff yeah like tracking like maybe
getting inside of like a someone who
might shoot up someplace like Marian can
like but how would they it how was uh
Coburg what does it say about his
involvement he's just like this one
Nader Regina Dugan who's part of
Facebook now she's working on a
secretive in a secretive division of
Facebook just to just as you see here it
says like you can end up typing the hard
words per minute just with your eyes
with your smartphone you know what's
amazing about about face was black
Facebook Facebook has a shitload of data
on how people behave and have all kinds
of social sciences like docker Keltner
and stuff FATA berkeley who are social
scientists who study like psychological
trends and mass you know and they have
found some [ __ ] amazing stuff about
like like because a lot of times people
say they posted this picture of me I
want it off on their on their page and
somebody at Facebook has to go and look
at that picture and make a judgment call
on whether or not they can take that
picture off for paper right because
you're infringing on their privacy but
it all comes down mostly to
embarrassment a lot of people just don't
want that picture on their committee
looks shitty Fischer like I've ever
taken on is also the animals epidemic
getting tagged when you don't want to be
telling like a lot of people do that
like I'll go to tag certain comedians or
whatever friends and Psyche they cannot
be tagged in pictures like yeah come on
relax and feel like you miss out on a
lot of [ __ ] too unless you're just a
shady person who'll be tagged yeah
lesson learned man don't be Shady and
maybe those tags won't be such so yeah
what else you got [ __ ] all right last
one brother last one this one's trip
because I've done this before but it was
a great picture of Zuckerberg what's
nuts I'm a tiger if he's looking for a
man convicted of manslaughter a fixative
manslaughter convicted of manslaughter
after knocking down a wasp nests at his
buddy's house oh god damn it
the nest fell down and the 102 some of
the wasps went over to the neighbor's
house stung both the neighbors and the
man one of the men are where the
neighbors died from it that's all that
fair and relaxing shot does that mean
you're allergic bees yep dammit he's
convicted of it so it's just not Wow
ten years bro
no no that's the thing so this is all
Berlin - it was only like 90 days in
jail or he could pay a fine and he could
pay the fine with like 95 or $9,000 Oh
Switzerland it's all good baby
yeah they said she was trying to clear
it from a friend's home you think he was
trying to I mean obviously if you're
trying to swat a business you're trying
to get rid of it just you know Swiss
wrong it wasn't even on the other side
it was on there huh like his buddy's
house that he was at but it just the DS
went to the other side to the neighbor's
house and stung the neighbors or some
dough it surely Hollywood you'd be
convicted of manslaughter but they said
it was neglect
let's switch that's en slippery slope
man he's trying to help us do doubt and
then [ __ ] [ __ ] not a yeah you got a
Chuck that I was like a tragic that's a
tragic situation also exception I just
don't want a bunch of wasps stinging me
ever
now a little horrible way to die on my
way we'll call the UH what happens when
you get done when you go into
anaphylactic shock you just you swell up
and then yeah your throat just the be
like get real close and be like you
[ __ ] you desert like you had this
come like this something happened you
whispers in your ear good night sweet
prince
dude yeah let's go Denver Wausau my
heart is pretty good well that's how the
beat the B movie ended that's right it
was fine so that's - I hope the PISA in
bed he did that night sweet prince and
then he [ __ ] killed that family kid I
would leave movie right yes yeah oh gee
yeah like a bleep cycle did that
alright that's [ __ ] terrible shame
well I don't know condition code 90 90
days but then you're saying he'll get 10
more no I mean in the US manslaughter
can be 10 years in Switzerland it's all
good they don't like it so it's not like
you're going to ski only one slope for
90 days yeah now how many jokes you
think are gonna be made when he goes to
jail when he comes and people came back
dude we heard the buzz on all your
[ __ ] how you got in here like the
exact dude that was [ __ ] I had to
sting man that if I can you come in not
going to say bye to your families do
people do that probably yeah we don't
want me to swarm you but you're kind of
a celebrity artist I was looking for the
third one that was it
that's the winner's circle yeah why loss
do you want to eat hey I hate what honey
with that team and hey bring up what
bring up a Swiss Chiana see what a Swiss
cheer looks like supposed to be
looks like Four Seasons yeah a swiss
jail yeah that's brilliant
[ __ ] yeah a la images yeah I'm here
surround that no way that an Airbnb in
Burbank ha ha ha ha ha the jails are
amazing I have heard of yeah it's great
look at how clean there dude the best
women the best jails good food yeah
slide well I got a dream up there you go
look at this life inside a Swiss prison
well that's a chateau pools we could I
compared ours
dude arts and crafts and I got hearts
and Carla
either way it's [ __ ] knife sounds
sweet so they are really nice yeah just
drop the knowledge base yeah you're like
you've dropped a shitload all just hide
it - real quick do you know what a
fundamentalist fundamentalist is do you
know how to define a fundamental to find
it for us what do you think it is I
don't know man somebody who eats like
Tim Duncan right use the backboard
what do you define a Mantle's god dammit
no all right let me finish it's all
about me like a dough Duncan but it's
not Tim Duncan you know it's a guy who
understands fundamentals yeah
but then goes I'm not yet to where I
want to be where I'm considered a
fundamentalist and then he watches The
Mentalist now and then it's got a damn
it no that's not it
oh well so if you're a Christian
fundamentalist if you're an Islamic
fundamentalist told me that's all the
fundamental I Q believe in just that uh
no well in a way one track you believe
is that that isn't matter to a literal
truth
yes it's the truth with a capital T
there is no other truth only that so a
Christian fundamentalist usually will
actually believe in the entire Bible the
Old and New Testament probably and they
believe it literally as in God created
the world does no metaphors or
references I just literally yes but I
just want to ask our listeners to think
about your own life and where are you a
fundamentalist because we are surrounded
by fundamentalists especially in
political discourse libertarians
nowadays the libertarian is like all
government is bad all of it and all
governments bad so it should be all free
market and then you
you know when you get the way academics
on the progressive left talking it's
like all men you know men are toxic and
there are predatory conspiracy and take
way to the world it's just conspiracy
theory goes guys they everything's a
conspiracy yes I say those stole
everyone you think that's leaks
everybody all over everything is
conspiracy nothing's real that's right
and that would be fun that's a form of
fundamental correct right in other words
everybody's lying to us and I only have
my one source of truth and it's over
here that's exactly right so just be
aware that that is the enemy of progress
that is the enemy of thought and that is
probably a friend to all things not so
good because being a fundamentalist is
probably very similar to being a fanatic
when you're a fan right you're a fanatic
there it is so take a little inventory
of how your own brain works then evil
thoughts phones running town and I back
that back we'll be right back
are you looking for a sweet sweet
strawberry razzmatazz hi I'm Brian
Collins for an Adam ray when he's not in
the corner with the shirt on off off
something cut take time Adam ray Brian
Collins friend when I'm not doing
stand-up comedy I'm watching Brian Cowen
drink a big old glass or strawberry
razzmatazz get a boost actually know
what that Kalin boosted for you yes
choice can you describe me just go up
Brian calm he's got sandy brown hair a
crooked smile a crooked teeth less
straight no straight teeth kind of
crooked smile and and and with and then
just describe my my piece this is weird
welcome back to dick talk I'm your host
Gregory Payne GP for short
today's topic is Bryan Callen sandy
brown hair blonde hair looks down in the
sunlight sometimes straight jaw sharp
teeth that piece you know what that
piece looks like Google Images Stallion
a black one or a brown one depending on
the week
I think I'll cut a piece of bread what
my dick isn't that short dude [ __ ] all
right you know what that's enough
Adam ray can make a sandwich with that
we can find the item at Adam rate comedy
on Twitter and Instagram
Adam rate tv.com for my tour dates we
got coming up coming up uh the craft
shoe comedy festivals new festival in
Las Vegas
um 18th through the 20th and then a Reno
Laugh Factory Reno I was just kidding
earlier uh I already know but uh but I
will talk about that bring them up let
me see you Adam right TV that's great
and then tour dates their tour dates are
all there to them parlor in Seattle cap
city in Austin oh I love that I love
that room hope you at the ice house
oh yeah look like a local shows for a
while I think I got your all over
brother and I'm gonna see me in uh
Vancouver May 4 or 5 out of exon
yeah there you go Brian oh you say with
the return of the Mack on pop TV
Wednesdays at 8:30 overturn the Mac now
you go B nevermind it's work mine yeah
Lee Miller Oh swimming very Cooper [ __ ]
I don't have [ __ ] look how many weeks
I saw that you're bigger were five and
six I like that you do that plant yeah
yeah
Fontaine your picture you posted fool it
was great thanks buddy garage really a
man a bit the ice house may third my
show Thursday night to come store in La
Jolla is sold out it's only one yeah may
3rd ice house that is next Wednesday
everything you can get at T fat K calm
you can see my boy Adam ray he's all
over crazy this is a fire kid with Adam
ray we're out